instagram feiert seinen zehnten
geburtstag mittlerweile eines der
mächtigsten medien des planeten und was
man damit alles machen kann
vor allem voll süß aussehen soll oder
nicht zuletzt dank instagram wird
deutschland immer mehr zur hälfe kratie
und eine unserer ältesten influenza
rinnen bringt hier mal das ganze prinzip
social media wunderbar auf den punkt
übrigens mein allererstes interview war
wirklich sehr interessant ja als erstes
interview im leben sonst machen sie
immer nur selbstdarstellung charmant
frau kanzlerin
würden sie sich für selbstdarstellung
interessieren kann ich ihnen ein
praktikum bei christian lindner besorgen
dank erster gerade beschäftigen sich
über eine milliarde menschen auf der
welt jeden tag mit selbstdarstellung
manche offensichtlich sogar rund um die
uhr er sich merken wenn ein handy auch
nur kaputt ist oder der akku leer ist
diese zeitspanne bis man sein handy
wieder in der hand hat und wieder mit
sozialen netzwerken konfrontiert werden
kann
das ist komisch weil da fehlt
irgendetwas das riesenloch
dieses loch nennen wir älteren übrigens
das leben voll ein
instagram macht süchtig soll süchtig
machen inklusive entzugserscheinungen
wenn nur drei sekunden kein netz hat
leitet sofort unter posttraumatischer
belastungsstörung instagram wo man fotos
von sonnenuntergängen oder avocado
bowles postet die man niemals essen
würde weil davon nimmt man ja zu uns zu
nehmen geht auf instagram wirklich gar
nicht für das foto links gab es likes
für das rechts kritik für ihren
sinneswandel hate fettes mastschwein
wird sie genannt
ja mein gott als ich das geschrieben ab
saß ich gerade frustriert am rechner mit
einem eimer hegen das ist ja auch gar
nicht das thema ich finde es tatsächlich
schlimm wie gerade junge mädchen von
diesen falschen instagram ideal unter
druck gesetzt werden ja studien zeigen
einen zusammenhang zwischen social media
und depression
das kommt davon wenn man sich ständig
mit geschönten bildern vergleicht die
genauso echt sind wie das wahlergebnis
in belarus und eine weitere wirklich
schlimme insta nebenwirkung an richtig
schönen orten wie hier am königsbach
wasserfall drängeln sich scharen von in
stalkern um alle exakt dasselbe foto zu
machen
12.15 park entstanden da in der schlange
um dieses foto zu machen
das mädel üblicherweise in die klinik
friert und wartet bis der pool freies
muss dann reinhoff untersucht der
günstiges günstige flächen für sein foto
ja diese armen buben während man
übrigens ins tableau friends das ist die
niedrigste form der gattung männlicher
homo sapiens influenza an schönen orten
sie lachen aber die sind inzwischen
tatsächlich so was wie eine biblische
plage der bnd und der wwf informieren
jahre lang dachten wir der klimawandel
ist die größte gefahr für unseren
planeten zusammen mit der
luftverschmutzung und im outen sterben
dabei haben wir die wahre bedrohung
leider übersehen die gottverdammten die
influenza sie zertrampeln für ihre
beschissenen service ganze
lavendelfelder in frankreich stürmen
unschuldige back davor in den alpen oder
quellen für ihre selbstdarstellung
orgien unschuldige tiere liebe influenza
im namen der natur hört auf mit dem
scheiß bleibt gefälligst mit eurem arsch
zu hause und werdet der influenza
danke ja drin bleiben rettet quasi leben
zwischen 2011 und 17 kamen über 250
menschen bei selfoss ums leben instagram
eine hochglanz gute laune maschine mit
gewissen schattenseite ist so
rechtsextreme zum beispiel haben hier
wieder mal einen weg gefunden den alten
algorithmus zu überlisten und zwar mit
subtiler influenza bildsprache gucken
sie mal hier denkt man ein süßes baby
mit plüsch wolff holtz schwert und einer
bastelarbeit die aussieht wie alle mal
mehrere hakenkreuze richtig die schwarze
sonne so was wie das mandala der nazis
das recherche zentrum korrektiv hat
neulich ein erschrecken großes insta
netzwerk von rechten in florenz dann
aufgedeckt inklusive junge alternative
und identität bewegung die schicken
skrupellos babys vor und nicht nur das
also frauen und das hat mit unserer
verschiedene experten und dann bestätigt
werden häufig vorgeschickt eben mit
unschuldigen inhalten mit normalen
inhalten um dann eben da in den
kommentaren diskussion anzuregen oder
ein politisches thema zu platzieren und
sie werden dann quasi wie auch im realen
leben vorgeschickt also demonstrationen
der identitäten bewegung beispielsweise
werden häufiger auch von frauen
angemeldet als von männern weil frauen
harmloser wirken weil sie unpolitischer
wirken ja wirklich per viele frauen
locken dich mit rechter propaganda das
gab es wirklich nicht mehr zeitz l
riefenstahl damals die junge alternative
berlin hat zum beispiel angeblich mehr
als die hälfte ihrer neuzugänge über
instagram angeworben ganz wichtiges
instrument für die afd
auch wenn es in der umsetzung oft noch
hat der mädels mein name ist das kunst
aus dresden und ist keine leere für das
europäische parlament
wir brauchen eine willkommens politik
für kinder deswegen bin ich auch auf
kindergeld ich bin dein fw keine zum
anfassen
[Musik]
trotzdem glückwunsch instagram zum
jubiläum und wir schalten jetzt mal live
auf die instagram seite eines der
erfolglosesten influenza ostdeutschlands
olaf schubert kritiker sagen ja dass er
eine geschönte kuschel version des
richtigen lebens
was fasziniert dich so an instagram und
wozu nutzt du dass es stimmt also in
study wir fachleute sagen ist es nicht
unbedingt die faktenbasierte öde
realität es ist eher sowas wie
volkstümlicher schlager in virtuell und
gerade deshalb ist es ja auch so
erfolgreicher instagram hat sich
durchgesetzt gegen die knallharte
konkurrenz wie jetzt eben zum beispiel
in zdf teletext und trotzdem nutze ich
instagram unbewusst auch sozialkritische
inhalte zu posten also ich engagiere
mich auf install kann zum beispiel für
albino katzen oder treibt einige karten
und auch hierfür menschen ja auch für
menschen mache ich mich stark wenn ich
dann zum beispiel eben schreibe hier der
ist mega fotos oh ja jetzt hast du ja
sehr sehr viele kinder wie reglementiert
zu deren social media verhalten also ich
lade als erstes zum beispiel jetzt nicht
alles was die kinder betrifft hoch also
zum beispiel heute habe ich ein foto
gepostet auf dem zum beispiel nur einige
meiner jüngeren kinder zu sehen sind und
mir geht es vor allem darum dass die
kinder natürlich groß werden ja also es
gibt deshalb eben nicht nur computer
wenn die kinder jetzt 45 stunden online
waren dann sage ich so jetzt ist schluss
jetzt wird's angeschaut
sie brauchen beides für die entwicklung
und die medienkompetenz ist mir
natürlich wichtig also dass die kinder
erfahren welche inhalte sie von sich ins
netz geben und meiner tochter habe ich
zum beispiel erlaubt dass sie fotos
hochladen darf und meinem sohn
hab ich's verboten ja also ich habe
ihnen gesagt pass auf so wie du
aussiehst das kannst du einfach nicht
anbieten du machst dich ja komplett
lächerlich
das findet dann aber auf mich zurück und
da ist es eben wichtig dass man die
kinder betreut ganz behutsam natürlich
und sie auch vor sich selbst schützt
jetzt setzt ja instagram offensichtlich
gerade junge menschen sehr unter druck
immer schön immer perfekt zu sein
wie gehst du persönlich damit das ist
für mich natürlich auch eine große
verantwortung dass ich mich auch ein
großer druck zu wissen dass alles so
aussehen wollen wie ich und mir
attraktiven haben es leichter es gibt ja
diese studie sehr interessant eine
attraktive frau bekommt er im netz viel
öfter gesagt sie sind aber attraktiv
also jetzt im verhältnis zu einer
anderen frau bei der man ihre sache klar
so einen muss es auch geben und
schönheit beruhte auf symmetrie ja also
wenn jetzt beide gesichtshälften gleich
sind dann gilt es schön aber symmetrie
alleine ist jetzt wiederum keine
garantie für schönheit also wenn jetzt
beide gesetz selten gleich sind dann ist
es bei den meisten ja er
doppeltes pech ja und da kann man bei
instagram halt viel kaschieren mit
technik also meinen kindern empfehle ich
immer den einsatz von filtern und
weichzeichnen und das finde ich
wesentlich vernünftiger als eben jetzt
zu raten da sie sich jetzt operieren
sollen
das ist dann eher eigenverantwortung
also das müssen dann die kinder selber
entscheiden später wenn sie 12 sind
klingen vernünftig olaf schubert vielen
dank
was wieviel und und alles sobald wir
eine million abonnenten liebe liebe
liebe fans ich würde mich so was schon
freuen wenn ihr ein abo dallas auch hier
würde den gern so was von glücklich
macht